john kerry was um asked yesterday about
how he squares his
private jet habit with his fight against
climate change
i thought his answer is great because he
tries to explain
that actually he needs the private jet
in order to stop climate change
let's listen on that issue pollution i
understand that you came here with a
private jet
is that an environmental way to travel
if you offset
your carbon it's the only choice for
somebody like me
who is traveling the world to win this
battle
i negotiated the paris accords for the
united states
i've been involved in this fight for
years i negotiated with president xi to
bring president
xi to the table so we could get paris
and
i believe the time it takes me to get
somewhere i can't sail across the ocean
i have to fly
to meet with people and get things done
but what i'm doing
almost full time is working to win the
battle
of climate change and in the end uh if i
offset
and contribute my life to do this i'm
not going to be put on the defensive
offset my carbon uh
what's the science behind that how does
that work exactly what's the exchange
rate
does you have a chart or something you
tax up on the refrigerator so one
so you fly in a private jet one time and
then
recycle two milk cartons
and plant a tree and it and it's that
about equals
we're fair fair square earth okay don't
be mad at me
oh he has to fly around so he can do the
job well you can't do a zoom meeting
like everybody else has been doing
that's not going to be enough you have
to actually fly there and if you do fly
there you can't take commercial
oh you can't take a boat why not you're
the one telling us that
it's this is do or die the whole the
world might end
this is we're facing the apocalypse but
then we're trying to avert the
apocalypse
there there is nothing that should be
too radical
in trying to address that problem and in
fact people like john kerry and
democrats would agree with that usually
they would say there's no
alexandria cortez the green new deal
nothing is too radical
for us though see there is no sacrifice
too radical
for us for you for me but for john
kerry he can't even sacrifice sacrifices
private jet the rest of us can sacrifice
everything but
but not him that's the way it goes now
this is a common complaint it
is so common because it's how this
happens so often that the people who are
environmental champions are the ones who
are most guilty of
by their logic destroying the
environment but the problem is it
becomes almost
cliche to bring it up because we're so
used to it and it's it is
often viewed as almost a cheap shot
to bring up how people like this are
flying on private jets but it's not a
cheap shot
this is it's actually very important
any more than it's a cheap shot when
you've got a pastor or a priest at your
church who's involved in a sex scandal
if you go to that church and you care
about the sex scandal
that's not a cheap shot on your part
it's not irrelevant
because the fact that the pastor priest
is saying one thing in the pulpit
but then living this double life not
even trying to live by
the things that he preaches and his his
actual
lifestyle so completely contradicts
everything he says
well what that tells you is that he
doesn't really believe what he says
or at least it's a very good indication
of hypocrisy it's what hypocrisy is it's
saying things you don't believe
and you can't have someone leading your
church who doesn't believe the doctrines
can you climate change is its own
religious doctrine
and so it is it's it's very interesting
that almost all the high priests and
high priestesses
of climate change don't appear to really
believe the doctrine
and when this becomes so common then you
start to real then you start to think
maybe there's a problem with the
doctrine
the people who profess to know the most
about it and are the most focused on it
don't actually believe it in in their
personal life they take it about as
seriously as i do
which is i don't really take it
seriously at all but i'm still not
flying on private jets
that is a sacrifice that i have chosen
to make
not going on private jets well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date
on all of our future content